like what's our cultural problem what's
our
what's our cultural problem and then
what is the solution to
getting into that mode because
and trusting that i think it's i think
it's not even about trusting it as much
because i think once you see it you see
it but how do we keep ourselves in that
mode because even though i can repeat
these kinds of things to you in
awareness
there's something in my brain i don't
know if i'm just too high beta state at
times and
whatever it is but how do we get down to
that state where we are allowing and
flowing
and one with the universe instead of
constantly pushing against it it's
really is i didn't realize what i was
doing when i was doing it these days i
understand what i was doing and and and
i
i have practiced
um very deliberately to surrender and
let go
and and so that is what i do
constantly constantly constantly
back then
i don't know how i did it but i would
just cut i just had such faith in the
universe because that was the way that i
described it
and i i had set the biggest intentions
for the secret and i just knew that
everything would happen for us so we're
very much in the flow and if we were not
we stopped
and we were and we just walked away
until we felt good we came back and and
would continue working when we felt good
when i didn't feel good i would not
answer the phone i would not open my
computer i would not do any of those
things because if you're on a really bad
frequency and you open up your computer
in comes a whole lot of problems it's so
good on the same frequency so i just
wouldn't open my computer and uh
wouldn't answer my phone
until i would until i could feel a whole
lot better and so that was very
deliberate way that i did it then these
days
is very different i don't have such a
personal
attachment to i am doing this
you know with the universe the universe
is doing this for me
i am the universe
kind of one
with the universe
and so
i
i am just in the complete
state of
allowing surrendering letting go
because
we are the ones that need to get out of
the way
because everything that will be given to
us that will happen for us
is way beyond what we could even imagine
for ourselves
i could imagine it i'd be striving for
it but when you let go
of your own idea of how something could
go you're now open to the quantum field
of all potentiality that goes
far far beyond what our imagination has
even
conceived experience seen or caught a
glimpse of exactly exactly because all
we can imagine is the mind and the mind
is tends to be a recycling machine and
then as you say in the quantum area or
beyond the mind is
every single possibility unlimited
possibilities and so
yeah i just keep surrendering
to all of that and the less
we put ourselves in the way with our
fixed ideas and opinions and all of
those things you know
and we we kind of get those out of the
way the more magnificent our life
becomes
absolutely magnificent
i've found that the
human experience is challenging because
it takes experiences
patterns
relationships friendships
family it takes all these dynamics that
push on us to see ourself
and it's hard to see yourself and so
how did you get to that point where you
could kind of release and surrender and
get to that point
did you have
did you process anything about childhood
was there anything about your upbringing
something about family something about
your own patterning or were you able to
just
not have to go there and access this
potentiality
with
the simple awareness of the secret
right i saw
um in 216 i
had a revelation of who we really are
and so
that is what really changed everything
um
and
and even i think in secret i would refer
we are the infinite being you know i
would say it in the secret and and
i
definitely
believed that felt that um knew that
it's just that in 216 i had the
experience of it
and so i realized then
that the person is absolutely the
smallest smallest tiniest part of us
and
so basically i just spent my time
releasing
any
negativity that arises any
memories that arise because i know that
any negativity that appears or that that
that somebody else triggers with
negative feelings or negative thoughts
any um
uh any memories appear because they're
ready to be released from our life
that's why they're appearing they're
ready to be free
and so i know those things are inside of
us held in our subconscious mind and
when they appear they're ready to be
free so i learned how to release them
really quickly and
and
it applies to everything
that you
everything negative everything that we
consider negative but i only release the
things that appear and uh and if
if a negative feeling comes along like
like agitation or disappointment like
i'd get so excited
because it wouldn't mean i could release
it and in the releasing of it once
you've released it all you'll never feel
it again
like there isn't anybody that can
aggravate you in the outside world the
only reason they can aggravate you is
because you have it inside you ready to
be released right which you know very
well so um
so i just kept releasing and releasing
and what i found was the more i released
the happier i got and so then i would
see things like i had beliefs that
didn't serve me
and i would just release the beliefs
that didn't serve me and oh my gosh then
that's beautiful and not overwhelming
not at all you know because in my mind i
think oh man get through all the trauma
like heal a lot of
like you know of ancestral things like
dig in but right like how do i get to
that
the way you're describing it and and
this is i think one of your many gifts
is to put things simply so it can be
comprehended and understood
is that just when it comes up you deal
with it so of course i'm curious what
was that thing that happened in 2016.
i i um
i had another kind of uh
um moment
um i had another moment i had a
circumstance happen with a house that i
was selling and it ended up that i felt
this it fell through really quickly and
after i'd made all these plans to kind
of move out in a week and
i felt this incredible disappointment in
my body and i was just like how could i
feel
something like this when i always feel
so good i just didn't understand it and
so what i what i did was i just decided
i wanted to watch something spiritual i
didn't want this feeling and so i just
wanted to watch something spiritual so
the feeling would go away and i turned
on my computer and conscious tv and they
were interviewing a man called david
bingham who's just an everyday person
like you and me not a teacher or
anything like that and he talked about
how
he saw the truth
and became free
and i was like the truth
and i followed in his footsteps and did
what he did which he listened to a
podcast
and by a man called john wheeler i
listened to that podcast
and you know it's really interesting
because i watched the conscious tv
interview with him several times i
listened to the podcast multiple times
and then i reached out to david to speak
to him and this was over a period of
uh
three or so days and then when i spoke
to david
um he sort of did an experiment with me
where he showed me
the the
my mind focusing
and what's there if my mind
isn't
focusing what's behind my mind and has
been there
the entire time for my whole life
yeah
and it was
i was just
wow
and david said to me you'd already seen
it before we got on the phone and i said
had i really and he and he said yes but
all i know is
those few things and i saw
who i was from my own experience the
unlimitedness of who we are
and that there are no boundaries and
and so everything changed again
massively the way i see the world and
it's the second
huge step to freedom
right well it's just our perception
that colors are our world
we it's not always nice sometimes we
have things that happen to us we have
patterning from parents patterning from
friends and then growing up an
environment television
we have all kinds of different things
that give us a perception
and again since it's so hard to see
ourselves it's like you have to have
these moments right where you go oh
so what is the letting go process then
so the technique to help release things
and i keep working on it all of the time
because
um
in fact i just said to my daughter i
have to find a simpler way of saying
this
i just want it to be simpler and i've
covered it in my book the greatest
secret but i still
like i'm always looking for simpler
simpler simple ways so
one of the things just to understand so
people can get the feeling
is one of the things that we do
is we resist all the way along in our
life we resist when something happens
that we don't want to happen
and i don't want that we resist and so
we we're kind of um
enjoying like the things we like but the
things we don't like we like pushing
them away including
including people or a comment that
somebody makes we don't like that
comment and it affects us
and so
um and so that's all resistance and
resistance is what causes all the
negative feelings and contractions
inside of us
and so what releasing does is it stops
us from resisting
and so
it
if a
negative subject arises a negative
memory a negative feeling it is because
we have just resisted and so to
counteract that resisting and stop that
resisting we do the opposite to
resisting and so what we do is like i
could say just like relax but i say
welcome it
welcome the feeling welcome the the
memory
welcome the thought
and it's really just that we
we
don't try and fix it we don't try and
change it we don't try and make it go
away we don't try and do anything to it
we just allow it
to be there and in the allowing of it to
be there we stop resisting and it just
the energy
just evaporates and very often you can
feel the energy unwinding in your chest
it's just an automatic cleansing system
in our body the moment we stop resisting
everything unwinds and so
you could just do this if if nothing
appeared you could just be really
relaxed and just
allowing of everything to be just the
way it is right now and so to be very
present as well of course helps to do
that
and then ev all the energy that is
trapped just begins to unwind and be
released
and why we don't need to go through
picking one trauma one memory after
another
is because
that many of them attach like a train
with carriages and so we can get one and
it just pulls the whole train
of carriages out at the same time
and takes a whole takes a whole lot of
memories with it and so we don't need to
go through anything one by one
we just need to see the ones that appear
the ones that are triggered the
you know the feelings that
that are triggered by an outside event i
know that you talked about mirroring and
and that's what's so beautiful is that i
mean i can use the universe as an
example we'll use people circumstances
and events
it will use all of those things to show
us
what needs to be released